we all know someone right now in our
life where we have who's not ethical
who's not a good person who's winning
and you're like I can't believe they're
getting it right why can't I I'm a good
person I treat people while I'm honest
most people's will to win is for sale
it's for sale most people's will will is
for sale win is for sale they can be Bob
I can't be Bob the comfortable Road will
never lead you to the person you were
destined to be ever in your life need
motivation what to top ten with believe
nation what's up believe nation it's
heaven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference in the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew on today's lessons from a
man who went from growing up in a
middle-class family to building one of
the most successful financial service
businesses to now being one of the top
motivational speakers in the world
he's ed my lat and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one - my personal favorite alter your
beliefs there's this Governor on our
lives and it is a governor and it's a
it's your identity it's this internal
it's what you think you're worth it's
what you think you deserve and the
problem for good people seat we all know
someone right now in our life where we
have who's not ethical who's not a good
person who's winning and you're like I
can't believe they're getting it right
why can't I I'm a good person I treat
people while I'm honest
here's a reason why by the way the
unethical person eventually karma you
reap what you sow comes home to roost
but if you're a good person this is so
important people understand this because
it took me a long time a good person in
any endeavor will only take from it what
they think they deserve what they think
they're worth in other words if there
was a pizza here you're a good person
you don't take all 12 pieces a good
person thinks there should be an
equitable distribution layer so I might
take seven or eight arm-wrestle you for
I don't know about a your mousse but but
long story short what is is that you a
good person will not take more from the
table of life than they think they're
worth or they think they deserve and so
you have this Governor on your identity
so what happens is our it's like a
thermostat our lives get going we
started doing really well if we're a 75
degree or and our life gets to 85 and 90
degrees unconsciously we go we don't
know we're doing it oh we we start to
cool life back down to get it back to
where we're comfortable that reverse is
also true when things start to go really
bad and you're broke and you're
struggling you find a way to heat your
life back up to what you think you're
worth and you deserve so the way we
alter our life is sure we got alter our
behavior and our relationships and our
circumstances but the only way it's
permanent is that we alter that Governor
that thermostat and we start to believe
we're worth 85 degrees of life 95
degrees of life 110 degrees of life and
there's ways we can alter that how do we
alter it a couple different ways a one
is what you just said is that you put
yourself in circumstances that are
demanding if you pass what you think
your capacity is and when you succeed at
them you build a new water line you do
you throw yourself out there past where
you're comfortable and you do an 85
degrees behavior and you knock it out of
the park and go
brain starts to believe it repetitiously
when you start doing that you build a
new line now you're 85 degrees that's
number one
the second way though is Association if
you're around people and whatever that
endeavor is if it's a sport you're in or
if it's a business or your faith or your
peace if you begin to associate with
people who live in that space at a
higher temperature than you through
association you get heat it up yeah so
if you're an athlete for example you're
a 70-degree athlete and you start
training all the time with 85 and 90
degrees your identity through osmosis
goes up if your person is trying to
improve their faith in their life or
their their personal piece about them
you all know this you've seen it when
you start to hang around people that are
a little bit more peaceful than you or
meditate a little bit more through that
association over time the thermostat
changes in that area and so it's both
behaving in certain way and then your
associations yeah I believe that rule
number two don't sell your will to win
most people's will to win is for sale
it's for sale most people's will will is
for sale win is for sale they can be Bob
I can't be Bob so if we give you just
most people if we gave me just enough
money if there's a certain dollar amount
it's not working do you stop working
hard we give you a car or a plane or a
house or that's if the book broke that's
the book that the book yeah that might
be the book that is the book it so what
you're a will to win is for sale that's
right and I decided once I realized that
because I watched it happen with people
in their body and their finances and
their family and their faith whatever it
is I want I'm not for sale so there
isn't a place you're gonna buy me you
can't get me there's not a stop a place
a destination where you're gonna get me
to coolant to quit I want to improve
that doesn't mean I don't struggle with
my motivation from time to time doesn't
mean I don't get confused or down of
course idea I'm not for sale
yeah you can't buy me and you know this
too we see a friends of ours even guys
in their 60s and they sold their company
for blah blah blah now they golf nine
days a week or whatever you know that's
fun but you know for sale they burbot
you or buy you were for sale I'm not for
sale rule number three serve people
everything in your life happens for you
not to you I'm just a huge believer in
that and so my baseball dream ended I
had an injury probably gave me a
premature and to occur that would have
ended anyways in hindsight because I
played with enough great players that I
kind of know there was a gap in just God
an ability level not work ethic but yeah
I think to be the greatest there has to
be some proclivity for it and work ethic
right and so I kind of maxed out my
limited abilities and so when I got
released I ended up moving back home
with my parents I couldn't find a job I
was depressed I spent about a year at my
parents house just broke in every way
financially spiritually mentally
physically I remember my dad came home
my dad had just got sober and my dad
said to me hey I met this guy at a
meeting I got you a job you get your ass
down there tomorrow morning at 6:00 a.m.
getting out of this house getting a job
and I'm like okay I have a college
degree
you know I'm being picky for a year
watching Maury Povich reruns every day
on TV and Jerry Springer I go down there
at 6:00 a.m. I walk in I said hey my
name is Eddie my let him here for the
job they're like what job I remember
this vividly right and I'm like I don't
know they just told me you know and they
go we have no idea who you are and we
don't know what the job is they said do
you know who's hiring you I said I don't
remember then they go well then you need
to come back and I go to the door and I
go wait a minute
his name's Tim they're like there's a
lot of tins and I go well I know he must
be an alcoholic because he was at a
meeting with my dad laughter they go oh
drunk Tim we know Tim right and where I
was was a place called McKinley Home for
Boys it was a group home a campus of
group homes all my boys were Ward's of
the court they were removed from their
family either because their parents were
incarcerated killed or were molesting
them and I ended up in cottage eight
cottage eight I had 12 boys they were 7
to 10 years old now I walk through that
door that morning not even knowing what
the job was and it transformed my life I
mean in an instant brother I just saw
these eyes these little boys and they
just wanted someone to love them and
believe in them and care about them and
I'd have this big belief that people
that go through any dysfunction and
their family or abuse as a kid I think
our eyes are different we just have
these different eyes man and so I could
connect with these guys mine wasn't as
severe as theirs but I knew what it was
like to have that kind of anxiety and
that kind of stress and that kind of
pressure put on you as a little boy and
I became like their father I was there
with him on Christmas and Halloween and
the birthdays and I lived with them and
it changed my world because in that
instant I went for me in this athlete
who was ego Wrecking
significants gonna get rich it's all
about me always when you're a good
athlete you knew this growing up was
always accolades all of a sudden in that
instant it became about serving people
making a difference something like oh
this is what makes me happy
oh I was actually born to serve and help
people crazy no one that never happened
playing baseball and while I worked
there two years into it
the financial business that I'm in came
along and I started in a part-time and
I'm the I was the rare young businessman
who approached the business world from a
place of service and giving and not
making money and ironically the more I
serve people the more I made a
difference the more I contributed the
more I was rewarded financially I didn't
do it for that reason but that's what
happened so that's how I got into the
business was actually and again
everything my dad wasn't an alcoholic
he's not at that meeting I don't get
that job and if he wasn't if it wasn't
alcoholic I wouldn't have connected with
those boys so all of that in hindsight
happened for me right and I've met the
financial business before that I'd have
flown out of it
I'd have been about ego making money and
when that didn't happen out of left and
so it all happened in the right sequence
rule number four overcome struggles I
kept my job at McKinley and part time I
started in the financial services
industry and started to build a team of
people and started to get my licenses
and that transition and I struggled like
every upstart entrepreneur does I think
it's like three to five years until you
really get a few clients you know not in
any business I don't care if it's
financial services tech a dry cleaners
entrepreneurs the first five years is
just full of false starts and get it
going then you don't you get it going
you take a step forward you take three
back it's constant false starts it's
constantly thinking you have it going
it's constantly negotiating in your mind
the price you're paying is it worth that
should I quit
should I give in on constantly I spent
the first five years daily contemplating
quitting yeah all the time because it's
not fun it wasn't fun and and even
there's just a part of you I think and
anything you're doing when you're
struggling is this really for me is this
my destiny should I be doing this and we
miss Reed failure from some sign you
know is this a sign I shouldn't be doing
it you know is this a sign I am you know
not cut out for this instead of looking
for signs that you can win right and so
I spent the first five years literally
trying to find ways to quit trying to
find ways to get out
struggling and struggling and struggling
and I went broke I lost a car and the
water turned off in my place I you know
I bought out my first house I ended up
having it foreclosed on eventually so
I'm not that house with the unicorns
that you saw right or my beach place
like that's all they after people don't
realize that there were just years and
years of of grinding and struggling and
worrying in the beginning and then then
I made some mental changes and some
shift yeah that altered my life then
again rule number five find mentors I
knew I wanted to be successful I think
like in most things like they show up
eventually but maybe they don't look
like the way you thought they look when
they show up right so I was gonna be
baseball player from the time I was a
little boy and be a major league base
four or five years old talking about
that no one player studying it telling
people I was gonna be one look in a
certain way trying to be athletic I'm a
little new gradually trying to build my
body up and build myself up and I did it
well I am I mean I mean but I got little
wrists and I don't do Pilates but like
you do but I do work out but but anyway
and the Pilates looks good on you you
look younger than I do brothers so but
anyway I did I did I did well grow up
wanting to be somebody and then I got a
mentor when I was really young Hall of
Fame baseball player named Rod Carew who
most of you out there would probably
know grabbed me when I was a young man
and started pouring it was that was
probably nine okay he grabbed and
started pouring I believe into me why
did he saw me to baseball camp saw that
I was a little guy I saw that I had some
potential I kind of swung like him and
batted like him huh and so I spent the
better part of my youth being mentored
and coached one-on-one by a Hall of Fame
baseball player and he is poor baseball
tools in the miniport belief you're
gonna be somebody someday you're gonna
do something great so I had somebody
might hear I respected believing in me
from when I was young I think that
helped me rule number six
chase discomfort I kind of grew up in
that space that is dangerous because
it's like a slow asphyxiation right I
grew up what I'd call like middle-class
but probably the lower side of
middle-class too so I think there's an
I've told you this I think there's an
advantage sometimes you're going up rich
because you got connections and you see
the right behaviors modeled maybe when
you're poor a lot of my buddies that are
successful now that we're poor they knew
what they didn't want they were fighting
they learned to struggle they grew up
sooner right they didn't they couldn't
make excuses they had to learn to be
self resilient the middle
difficult cuz goods the enemy are great
right and so it wasn't horrible it
wasn't like there wasn't food on the
table wasn't like I didn't get a present
on my birthday right so you kind of
start to think that's what like this no
one in my family ever talked about
dreaming or winnin or being wealthy same
time they weren't really running from
something either so there's like there
was no stimulus the tzimmes when your
pores to get out of their stem it's when
you're rich is to replicate it
there was no stimulus from where I'm
from and so probably the rarest
background when you meet somebody that's
successful is the middle it's actually
the rarest that you meet somebody
they're from the middle and so a lot of
your listeners come from that place cuz
most people are in the middle right and
so I'm sort of I think an example of
some of the things maybe you would need
to do to get out of that space to move
from good to some some form of greatness
in your life yeah yeah it's comfort
right that word comfort can be a killer
right and so that's exactly what I
wanted you to do point that out is
because so many of us do come from that
and also we're maybe existing in it
right now so true and how important is
it to stretch ourselves that you really
kind of get comfortable with discomfort
you do you need to do that Malcolm X is
a guy that I've read a lot about and
Malcolm X my favorite quote of Malcolm X
is that which you do not hate you will
eventually tolerate and so there has to
be this point in your life where what
you want is so much greater than where
you are you're in such discomfort in
other words the gap between what you're
dreaming of what you're destined to do
what you're capable of you're aware of
it compared to where you are that
tension between the two has a pull power
to it right and so it's difficult I mean
life that you're chasing that next
version of you there's this there's this
thing I'm it's just unbelievably
passionate about that is that I have
this theory that I've told you this
before but that I think that the end of
your life there's this place you come to
and I'm a Christian so I think at the
end of my life then I want the Lord to
go hey well done good and faithful
servant doesn't matter what your faith
is you probably are aware there's
history being made or an accounting but
I also think he's gonna go hey by the
way this is who you could have been I
think he introduces you to the person
you were capable of becoming I really
believe that at the end of your life
you're gonna get introduced to the
person you could have been you were
destined to be that he made
to be and so I'm chasing that dude
everyday I'm chasing that dude that's
the pull power for me every decision I
make the things I go through in my life
whether I'm gonna go to the gym whether
we make a phone call how me to eat does
it get me closer to that guy because I
think the best end of a life is well
done by the Lord and you're identical
twins with that person the bad end of a
life would be I meet this man I could
have been and we're total strangers I
mean we're just complete opposites I
know nothing about this guy there's no
familiarity at all and it means that I
went down these easy roads I took the
comfortable road the comfortable road
will never lead you to the person you
were destined to be ever in your life
and so I know if you don't become
obsessed with chasing that person you
end up never meeting them rule number
seven master the art of persuasion
persuasion anything so if you want to
persuade your children if you want to
persuade someone to take a look at your
faith if you want to persuade someone in
business if you want to persuade someone
to help you in anything or help them in
anything it's real simple for me monster
belief and so you can't transfer to me
that which you're not experiencing
yourself right so you can't give me a
people always trying to cope with a
magic word
the magic clothes the magic this and
there are words you shouldn't shouldn't
use in persuasion no question about it
right there think there are words that
are more effective in other words and
clearly to be successful in any business
you need to know what those words are in
your business the best persuaders the
best motivators the best speakers the
best physicians the best schoolteachers
the best parents are incredible
persuaders and what they do is they come
from a monster place of conviction and
belief that they can transfer you to
because people respond to energy much
more than they do words they respond to
what they feel not what they hear and
see here and see a real low level
influencers energy spirit transfer of
energy is what people respond to and so
I'm cognizant all the time of getting in
a state of total belief and certainty
about what it is that I'm gonna
represent or speaking of I'm speaking on
stage about a particular topic and then
transferring that energy into people and
that seems generic or hokey but it's
actually what great persuaders do in
fact if you're listening to this you
think of anybody that you know who's
incredibly persuasive they may have
great words they probably do but it's
something you feel from them right and
that's the difference between
great doctor and a so-so doctor great
doctor says here's the prescription
you're out of here another one is they
kind of work or not about now the other
one you leave there feeling that you're
going to be healed settling you're in
good hands you feel their certainty you
feel their confidence saying when you
hear a speaker if you're buying real
estate from somebody but it's not just
buying things it's a great pastor in a
church a great person if you do TM who's
taught you TM it's there's certainty
it's the energy you feel and so for me
it's always getting to I have to really
believe what I'm saying I have to really
feel it to transfer to rule number eight
get up fast you and I watch this every
successful person that we know everyone
gets hammered man everyone gets knocked
down you get a you miss a close someone
changes their mind yet you get rejected
in the interview you you you lose your
baseball career whatever the hell it is
it's not whether you're getting knocked
down it's not even whether you get up
everybody eventually gets up everybody
gets up yeah it's the time you're on
your ass it's the time you stay on the
mat so what happened was my dream got
squashed instead of laying around for
six or eight months I was up immediately
like that day off the mat now my eyes
are open your eyes are closed when
you're on the mat yeah yeah so the
longer you stay on the mat just because
you've been defeated
you've now become blinded as you said
and it's prevented from getting any
other opportunity or blessings in your
life so the key is getting your butt up
like literally getting up and opening
your eyes again and chasing again you're
gonna get up so you might as well do it
now rule number nine rely on your habits
here's the thing I get asked all the
time how did you stay motivated all the
time people ask me that all the time and
the answer is I didn't and neither did
you to become successful the separator
in life is really important you'll think
the most inspired motivated person wins
not not really it's the person who can
work on the day's they're not inspired
and motivated it's what do you do when
you're not feeling great what do you do
when it's not your best day how do you
do that carries you through as rituals
and habits so when you're fatigued when
you're tired when you're under pressure
you react reflexively and so successful
people rely on habits and rituals not
just their inspiration and motivation
level of course we're both professionals
and being motivated and inspired but
that's not every day every minute and so
what do I do I work on the days because
my habits and rituals carry me through
and so for me here's how I look at my
in my day if I can control the first 30
minutes of my day and the last 30
minutes of my day I have a whole lot
better chance of the middle of my day
being controlled and so I'm a freak
about the first 30 minutes of every day
it's really about the first 45 minutes
and I'm obsessive about the last 45
minutes of every single day
that gives me some illusion in my mind
and measure of control the other thing
it does it delivers to me habits and
rituals that serve me that I do every
day that are consistent it gives me
comfort in stormy times that ocean out
there is raging at the top right now
right the waves are crashing at the
bottom of that ocean it's completely
calm at the bottom of that ocean is the
habitual part of the water right it's
the it's the it's the part of the water
it stays the most consistent that's why
it's so calm okay so when you see
someone out of control their emotions
are up and down all the time this is
someone who is without rituals and
habits successful people have those and
so they do and so it keeps me calm it
keeps me comfortable and rule number 10
the last time before a very special
bonus rule is be a champion this morning
was very unusual number one was the
water was unusually cold this morning
really cold and the waves were huge very
big waves this morning and both of those
things made me think about business and
there's an application for you that I
wanted to share with you the first one
was just getting into the water this
morning it was freezing
and when I had to get in there to make a
decision how do I get in do I kind of
take my time where I go my feet in first
kind of get adapt and then come out get
adapted go back in up to my waist get a
little warmer then come back and up to
my neck you get the deal then all that
would do is extend the pain all that
does it's logical it makes sense don't
go until you're ready take your time but
really all that does what does that
really do that extends the pain and so I
didn't do that I did what the pros do
right which is what people do in every
endeavor that are champions as I ran
Foom right at headlong right into the
water right you dive in Boop there's a
shock but then you get adapted so much
more quickly than you could possibly
imagine and then you're off to ride in
the waves well the same is true in
business the champions and everything I
don't care if it's your fitness if it's
your your family your faith you name it
the way that you get great at something
cuz you dive into it and get adapted
quickly and you'd be surprised at your
ability to adapt and navigate your way
through success the average people in
everything frankly the people who lose
are the ones who constantly take their
time they're too logical they think well
I can't do this until I'm ready if I'm
not ready I'll mess it up and I don't
want to get it's too cold it's too it's
too freezing well the truth is in
business that's not how it works if you
go slow you're extending the time you're
in pain and worse yet while the
champions have already dipped douve in
got acclimated they're out there riding
their waves making progress you're still
on the shore deciding whether you're
gonna get ready to get ready
so if you're an entrepreneur if you're a
business owner you're somebody getting
associated with my firm which is a
wonderful decision by the way but if
you're going to decide that you've got
to decide that and go and trust the fact
that you have your instincts your
background your training your mentors
the system around you and that's true
whether you're an entrepreneur in my
business or you're one of these firms
that I've spoken to on the outside I
want to encourage all of you if you're
going to get in get into business and go
you'll be amazed at Europe capacity to
evolve and to adapt and to succeed
now I've got a really special ed
mallette bonus clip on how to educate
yourself financially that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know what did you learn from Ed
today what clip resonated most with you
what change you're gonna make in your
business your life as a result of
watching this video put it in the
comments when you write it down you're
much more likely to actually follow
through so leave it in the comments
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
financially my formula is this and
you're not gonna hear this because
there's all this stuff on social media
know about baro baro baro baro first off
the bible says oh no man nothing so I
didn't get rich by creating debt and I
could just tell you that I don't care
about what type of debt you have but the
one thing financially is you do not want
to borrow money if you can minimize it
against a depreciating asset if you
borrow money for something that's going
to appreciate like a home or an
investment property I'm pretty cool with
that although I still think you should
be careful with a debt but I see far too
many people borrowing money against
something that depreciates like cars
that they don't need to have just to
impress other people right or close they
don't need to be wearing and so don't on
credit cards don't borrow money against
stuff that goes down in value as much as
you can't the second thing is live below
your means any person listening this can
get financially independent you have to
pay yourself first so believe it or not
as crazy as it sounds when I was broke I
still found a way to pay myself save
twenty five dollars save fifty dollars
because if you can't save money when
you're making a little bit of money you
are not going to save money when you
make more money you think you will but
you won't you continued to spend it and
so there was literally a year when I
started to make money you want to get
really wealthy I made several multiple
six figures one year and we lived in a
$700 a month apartment I just saved and
saved and saved and saved because my
confidence and business came from my
ability to acquire and save money over
time which took me a while but to mean
peace of mind is saving and cash cash is
king not enough people are obsessed with
saving cash and so live below your means
don't borrow money against stuff that
depreciate and save money and here's a
biggie start reading about money start
to familiarize yourself pick up some
books on finance start to know what
you're talking about
save your money here's the last thing
only put your money in something if it's
fifty dollars or fifty thousand dollars
that you completely understand if you
don't understand it set it in the bank
until you understand because too many
people are investing in stocks mutual
funds crypto this or that I'm not saying
don't invest in those places those are
good places potentially to invest but if
you don't understand them your money
should not be in there you're not a
professional gambler you're a saver and
an investor that's probably my biggest
ones on saving money if you tell
yourself a story long
have to believe it don't you believe you
act like I have Tulsa what a wail out of
handcuffed lightning though Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick
the fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access